begrüßen sie ganz herzlich zu dieser
heutigen sitzung in der es um formen des
unmoralischen gegen immer und mit thomas
von aquin befassen mit seiner theorie
der alltag ein
und wir wollen auch mehr machen wird
die grenzen des eigenen denkens und mehr
sehen und auch noch diesen sehr sehr
seltsam begriff der da heißt bullshit zu
deutsch bork misst das wirkt auf den
teams die sich in ordinären aber meine
form des unmoralischen haben es auch mit
ohne sparte zu tun das ist ganz klar
jedenfalls wollen wir uns auch mit
dieser theorie von harry frankfurt
auseinandersetzen
und ich denke das ist ganz gut
instruktiv weil diese theorie ist die
ist der theorie der lüge
gewissermaßen nicht genau
entgegengesetzt aber wer dieses phänomen
des kurses besteht der versteht auch
viel besser
das problem der lüge und das so also das
thema der heute 62 und wir haben schon
vier zuschauer sich gerade
erfreulich wie viel mehr muss man
schauen wir noch ein bisschen nachhelfen
zuerst so weit es vergeben wunderbar
dann kann's losgehen
zu beginn möchte ich noch ein bisschen
eine frage aufwerfen ein paar fragen die
die anlagen konzeption des seminars
generell betreffen jetzt also nicht nur
die besetzung und zwar kann man sich
fragen warum sollte man es überhaupt mit
dem unmoralischen befasst einfach
generell das haben sie sich bestimmt
auch gefragt als sie sich überlebt haben
dieses seminar zu besuchen
es sollten wir nicht lieber das
unmoralische philosophisch boykottieren
sie kennen alle dieses problem oder
diese ansicht dass sind auch etwas
heraufbeschwören kann indem man darüber
redet und das sind dinge vielleicht
lieber einfach ignoriert oder tod
schweigt dieses vielleicht nicht besser
der mir sehr mit dem phänomen des
unmoralischen gespeicherten
das gehäuse zu ist es das überhaupt gibt
es nie habe ich auch gesagt wir reden
damit das unmoralische ja also ist es
nicht vielleicht besser darüber
philosophischen zu sprechen
und was sagen wir konzentrieren uns nur
auf das gute nicht dass wir nachher auf
falsche gedanken dann kann man ja davon
ist das unmoralische hauptverlosung
begreifbar also ist das unmoralische
nicht viel mehr nur ein defizitärer
zustand einen mangel zu bestimmen wo
unsere vernunft sie einfach ja aussetzt
oder defizitäre oder ich weiß nicht was
sonst noch alles und könnte man nicht
sagen
auf die aus dieser wohnung kann man
darüber gar nicht entsprechend sind fünf
philosophisch es werde noch eine weitere
ansicht und dann kann man sich natürlich
fragen wie kommen wir überhaupt vom
orangen wenden uns damit intensiv
beschäftigt haben wieder zum moralischen
zurück gelingt uns diese rückweg oder
dieser aufstieg je nachdem wie man es
nimmt
diesen abschnitt zwischen hürden als
brat und sagen da kann man sich fragen
wie kommen wir zurück das sind so fragen
die ich einfach hier ihnen auch mal cent
geben möchte das können sie auch gerne
immer auf händel haus arbeitet er für
jede befassung mit diesem thema sich
überlegen so kann man das
ganze durchaus problematisieren ich kann
noch was kleines anderes erzählen
ich werde demnächst ein handbuch im
mobilitäts heraus gehören in diesem
handbuch wird alle formen des
unmoralischen ausführlich geschildert
und dieses seminar dient auch als
grundlage dazu als auch der verlage
haben daran interesse aber man muss ein
bisschen versorgungs arbeitsweisen damit
sowas überhaupt
ok also das sind diese grundfrage und
also meine these ist jetzt die oder das
ist das was nicht mehr folgen den markt
und bin natürlich offen für ihre
vorschläge
meine these ist die damit auch diese
frage beantworten
wir sollten uns überhaupt unbedingt mit
dem moralischen verfassen
wir sollten es nicht und schmerzen
besonders zu rational wie nur möglich
weil ich glaube wird das unmoralische
lässt sich vernünftig besprechen
ich glaube sogar dass es mit unserer
vernunft zu tun hat dass in unserer
vernunft in zenting eigenes vermögen der
rationalität des problems
angelegt ist das gehört zu uns findet um
trend war zusammen
die starke these würden viele plateau
monika also philosophin philosophen
platon anhängen bestreite ich glaube
oder nicht oder ob es echt man zwar
nicht zusammen und deswegen ist es die
ihm auch philosophisch begreifbar und
auf die letzte frage zum fünften kommen
nur dann zum moralischen wenn wir mal
beim homöopathischen angefangen haben
ich glaube es gibt keinen privilegierten
zugang keinen direkten unbenutzbar
zucker mit zu moralischen oder zu wurden
von immer nur jedenfalls proben des
menschen über das das ist meine these
und das kann man hier gerne diskutieren
und das können auch gerne die zuschauer
hier ein zuschauer auf youtube tun die
mir schon den sechsten like gerade
gegeben habe soviel zum thema ein
so und jetzt also zu den sieben
todsünden dann wissen sie den ordner als
werden das mit ihm aus diesem seminar
die reihenfolge der sieben todsünden
haben sie alles gelernt was sie lernen
müssen
ja
versuchen sie es machen
diesen
[Musik]
gut sehr gut also dass es das
grundgerüst unsere unser seminar und wir
haben jetzt gesehen mit dem hochmut
bekommen das heute zu tun
hochmut da geht es um die ganz tiefen
des eigentümers haben und wir werden
erst in jeder sitzung wie sie dem
seminarplan sehen können die mich immer
aktuell auch viel okaz auf der film cast
apple hatte da können sie immer ganz
aktuell sehen was wir gerade tun und
sich danach ausrichten weil wir hier ist
flexibel sind es kann sein
mit einem in einer sitzung bekommen ich
das durch was wegen täten und da müssen
wir halt einer anderen sitzung dieses
thema noch mal auf so zum beispiel auch
okay und jetzt mission impossible zu
diesem netten herrn
das tut es und zwar sehen wir dass ein
paar dinge aufgefallen die mir ab davor
noch nicht aufgefallen
also aristoteles so wie wir es jetzt
gelesen hatten jedenfalls mit
entscheidet zwei gattungen oder pausen
wie man zumindest moralischen nämlich
handlungen und affekte entziehen sich an
die freiheit das ist ein überfall über
maß an vorsicht und an die tollkühnheit
das ist ein übermaß an dem effekt
praktisch wenn man das überhaupt als
transit seite das können sie auch mit
beliebigen anderen dingen durchspielen
und dann gibt es natürlich handlungen
das ist klar die gibt es auch
und jetzt kann man sich aber fragen
genügen diese zwei karten handlungen und
effekte und des phänomens unmoralischen
erschließen zu erschöpfen zu behörden
oder gibts ja nicht nur eine dritte und
der vierte kategorien von phänomenen die
mögliche kandidaten für das unmoralische
sind und mir scheint es gibt zu ich
glaube nicht dass andere effekte
einzigen möglichen kandidaten für
unmoralisches desweiteren kennt er zwei
gründe des bösen nämlich unmäßigkeit und
unbeherrscht und wissen sie noch was für
arbeit
schlimmer bearbeiten um mäßigkeit
herr stein
er hatte das im vergleich gebracht
vielleicht ganz sicher hat gesagt um
mäßigkeit gleicht einer art von
krankheit erkrankung und
unbeherrschtheit einer anderen
erkrankung und hat diese erkrankung kann
man sehen dass das eine schlimmer ist
als das alte
[Musik]
genau
er hatte gesagt wissen sie noch diese
erkrankungsalter genannt hatte bei
wunder her streit genau ein anfall der
und epileptiker ist einfach nur
ergriffen werden man wird begriffen und
zwar einen moment für irgendetwas monate
weisen die was man zum gehirn aber eben
nur für einen moment für eine farce aber
dann geht es wieder normal weiter und
die mäßigkeit das war eine andere kamera
gesagt gilt als so was an dem wir leben
länger bleiben und nicht nur so fanden
ok und jetzt kann man sich natürlich
fragen ob er gefahren ist es voll
stellen
erstens man wollte ja ist es überhaupt
hatte vollständig klassifikation
phänomene geben
vielleicht findet sich in seinem
umfangreichen werk auch noch etwas
anderes nicht komplett ist nicht ganz
aber zumindest in der nigrischen fertig
gibt nur diese beispiel jetzt kann man
sich wirklich fragen reicht das aus
moralische handlungen oder effekte oder
was es sonst noch geben mag sagen als
meine handlungen entweder durch
mäßigkeit oder durch die
unbeherrschtheit zu erklären genügt das
als motive als antwort auf die frage
warum hast du das getan hat dass sie das
getan
der grund nach unmäßigkeit
unbeherrscht oder gibt sie noch dritte
sind das sogar ein viertes motiv für
unmoralische handlung oder wasser und
das möchte ich auch in frage stellen ich
glaube andere kandidaten als sehr krank
sind dass unterscheidung verstellen und
ein kandidat für eben noch eine andere
form einer gattung des unmoralischen
wäre es über sowie moralischen
motivation eine maxime wie katzi nennt
die feldrunde handlungen sind das
produkt von maxime oder von willens
einstellungen und effekte liegen vor den
bildungs einstellung oder einen ganz
anderen bereich
ich glaube das hat den die maximen
person die mir schon
mich würde es nicht wundern und zwar
deswegen weil der begriff des willens
wie wir ihn heute kennen
der hatte mit der antiken noch nicht so
viele anhänger
anders gesagt viele würden sagen den
modernen willens begriff die gab es
damals nach ghana
viele sagen erst augoustinos oder der
spätantike angehört hätte den begriff
des willens erfunden sagt zumindest
einer haben
augustinus ist auch sehr christlich
geprägt also das hängt auch ein bisschen
mit religiösen einflüssen zusammen dass
damit die reine willenskraft entwickelt
wurde man findet vielleicht bares
vorläufig auch bei platon wenn es in die
seelen wäre schauen an die vielen teile
gibt es den mannschaften zählen teil des
geplanten
aber ob es genau dieser moderne
bildungsbegriff ist im sinne dieser
individualität des wollens das
reflektieren das findet sich eigentlich
alles zufall
augustin 8 schon jetzt war mit dem
amerikaner haben dieses ganz bekannte
lügen beispiele hier diskutiert und auch
hier habe ich so ein paar anmerkungen
auch bekannt ist ganz wichtig
unterschied zwischen handlung und
maximen wiesen sie nach osten maxime war
ich kann es vielleicht auch noch mal hin
schreiben was ist die maxime
wissen sie noch
eigentlich ganz einfach da sind jetzt
kann ich ganz ausdrücklich darauf
gesprächen kommt mit maximilian
genaue perfektion und schreibst genau
ansehen
satz
wir haben unseren grundsatz ist
natürlich gemeint dass da noch nicht die
anderen selbst vollzogen wurde sondern
diese maxime die ermöglicht es die hand
man kann auch sagen ist der subjektive
tiefe wille ungefährlich weil ich genau
dasselbe machen dass objektive wille der
haben ausgedient oder willens grundsatz
kann also mich jetzt ich bin jetzt um
dieses
überzeugt dass das ziemlich will etwas
auf basis einer grundkurs
grundüberzeugung die aber koalition ahl
mit endlich verfasst ist
das ist also ganz zentral verkannt und
die handlung ist sie die handlung ist
das was aus einer bestimmten situation
unter bestimmten umständen die ich auch
nicht immer in der hand habe folge es
werden sich vielleicht an die
grundlegung präsidenten das erkannt gut
ist alleine guter wille und nicht die
handlung und nicht die folgende handlung
sind die sind alle funktionen nicht das
was ich selbst an einem der hand habe
und was mir an einen rückzug gerechnet
werden kann
strengstens ist mein wille oder meine
maxime mein grundsatz den ich mir
gewählt und alles andere die handlung
und was dann den zehn jahren und 1 5
minuten danach passiert das habe ich
nicht ganz in die hand weil das könnten
der umstände ein
die dazu führen dass zb eine böse
absicht dass die die schule raider wurde
oder dass sie eben sogar noch verstärkt
wurde
und das nennt man in der
angelsächsischen debatte diese zumindest
vor der em ende dieses fehlers eine
handlung eintreten kann sich verstärkung
kann oder auch abschwächen kann so dass
es eigentlich gar nicht wichtig in
meiner hand das nennt man
lös
das ist ein bisschen problematisch weil
neben tricks nicht mehr in der hand habe
es keine umstände eintreten die ihn böse
absicht noch viel mehr erschweren
ich kann etwas wissentlich in kauf
nehmen und den sie mal ein verbrecher
der in kauf nimmt dass er bei der flucht
einen menschen überfährt der einfach das
licht nicht an macht und dann einfach
ein bankräuber in der bank käuferin der
oder sie dann einfach los und wir kaufen
das er dabei jemand probiert wenn er
dass sie niemandem fährt wird er dafür
nicht angeklagt werden für diese
einstellung ich fahre jetzt einfach ohne
licht mal weg und flüchtete wenn er das
hier aber jemand erfährt wird er dass
sie angeklagt werden aufgrund von ich
weise als fahrlässige tötung
sie sehen es hängt letztendlich immer
auch ein bisschen verstecken und kann
würde sagen in städte wie chemnitz an
die zellen überhaupt nicht geschaut
egal was jetzt darf im stelle war das
dann erschwert und abgemeldet haben für
mich zählt nur die absicht nur abidal
ein musterbeispiel wird unsere maxime
dass alles richtig dann gibt es eben
diesen maximen testdaten das hatten wir
kurz gesagt da gibt's ich habe es eine
zusammenfassung geschrieben
es gibt zwei arten oder es gibt mehrere
formen dieses kategorische imperativ
einmal so dass es ein allgemeines gesetz
werden soll können muss die maxime
oder gibt es andere formen sagt dass es
die menschheit das der menschheit nicht
widersprechen so dass es die menschheit
nicht verletzt die menschheit jetzt
natürlich so verstanden so nana menschen
auf die idee der menschen und mit ende
der menschheit ist natürlich gemeint die
für die idee des vernünftigen
koexistieren 51 es ist eigentlich
wirklich schon jetzt sagen kann
die lüge dieses kategorische zu
verbieten oder zu unterlassen warum weil
sie der menschheit alle zu schade
und jetzt können sie da mal kurz bei
leben in niefern kante an die lüge wenn
sie noch so formal sei der menschheit so
wie wir sie jetzt verstanden haben
schaden was ist das argument verkannt
ich glaube eine eigene sicherheit zurück
[Musik]
das alles
ja genau wenn alle so hatten luther
seine maxime hätten dann könnte ich ja
niemandem mehr trauen
dann löst sich ja nicht ob er das sie
sein versprechen hält zum anspielen kann
bringt das beispiel das depositum dessen
ausgeliehener gegenstand ist und dann
würde ich geben dann würde das vertrauen
in die menschheit grundlegend
erschüttert
zumindest werden werden
[Musik]
ja
genau wie man bands einbreche wäre es
denn gut letztendlich für die menschheit
aber so ein lüge system das kann sich im
radikalisieren und wie sie diesen eine
lüge kann der weiteren erfordern nach
sich ziehen und so kann ein übungssystem
sich sogar auch radikalisieren und man
landet am ende etwas wo man da nicht hin
wollte es eine ganz einfache sie kennen
des weikersheimer erfahrungen kann
zimmer also ein bisschen gelogen so
eigentlich völlig harmlos
und da fragt die person so ein bisschen
hart und sie führen diese dinge
getrieben und dann müssen sie noch ein
bügel hinzunehmen und so verstricken sie
sich dann in seiner art teufelskreis
weil jede weitere lüge die prinzipien
angreifer ihrem in ihrer strategie und
dann werden es gewohnt sicher und sofort
oder ende befürchten sie ganz schlimme
dinge und es ist für sie ganz wichtig
dass das jahr nicht auffällt und so
können sie sich dann in etwas
der eingang mit errichtet was ich jetzt
nicht hier aber so was schon mal
vorgekommen
gibt es vielleicht auch die tragischen
vorgängen bestimmt
ok und hier sind auch ein ganz wichtiger
anderer punkt nämlich die kontingenz der
handlung
das war dieses thema also was am ende
rauskommt von einer praxis
das gibt ihnen von gewissen umständen
haben kann bringt bei diesen lügen
beispiel bei diesen verbrecher die
mörder der dieses auch verdampfen folge
dass auf grund sucht und sich daneben
lügen könnte oder auch die wahrheit
sagen kann der kann wenn ich jetzt auf
die frage des mörders des verfolgers ob
da sich das opfer versteckt die
unwahrheit sagen wird als sein würde es
versteckt sich nicht
dann könnte der fall eintreten dass der
mörder nicht beim je nachdem ob versucht
das opfer aber gerade eben mein haus
verlassen hat und sich der mörder macht
sich das opfer schnell weil wenig um die
wahrheit gesagt hätte hätte im
ausgesucht und dann wäre das auch für
eben nicht mehr ausgelöst und so durch
solche äußerungen bestimmt würde ich
mich dann sogar mit schuldig machen kann
das ist jetzt die frage ob das realität
ich wollte es ja nicht jedenfalls
designer ab seine these die wir sollten
wenn es um
bewertung von moralischen phänomen geht
immer nur auf unsere absicht die
vernünftig für allgemeine wagnisse sind
sich es nicht wissen wir nehmen sie
unterlassen oder die maxime ersetzen ja
da haben wir darüber diskutiert wie
sieht es denn aus wenn ich jetzt dem
mörder fand die wahrheit sage einfach
mich ist dieser mensch bei dir
untergetaucht und sie sagen ja dann
könnte man jetzt sagen da macht sich
ihnen vielleicht die beihilfe zum mord
schuldig oder unterlassene hilfeleistung
oder sonst wer von ihnen nach man immer
eine ganze abstimmung ist sie werden
nämlich gesehen werden wird es sagen
in so einem fall die pikante sagt
absolutes drogenverbot angesagt wer
würde das sagen und ich sage die andere
option noch die andere person
nein wir sind moralisch verpflichtet den
hörer anzunehmen damit wir uns nicht der
beihilfe zur schule also wer einmal mehr
wer würde sagt ich vertrete kann tische
auffassung wissen das und setzt sich
gerne melden plätze weil das ist eine
durchaus teilweise noch vertretene
auffassung und wer vertritt wie andere
auffassung
die mehrheit der ja also es ist es
schwierig die man kannte natürlich schon
recht geben so ganz passt aber ich
glaube was er unterschätzt ist die ganz
spezifische situation
er geht immer von generellen sucht und
er hat mir scheint keine ethik für die
konkrete situation und da würde alles
total es vorteile haben was tolles
wir müssen die freunde sehen sich die
front ist es dass unsere klugheit und
die klugheit muss aus extremsituation
das mittelmeer
aber das würde sagte dass unsere
urteilskraft ins komische klugheit wir
müssen von fall zu fall unterscheiden
wir können nicht generell regeln lassen
sondern müssen immer schauen wie sie
diese situation aus was kann ich wissen
wie kann ich die situation einschätzen
kann
die verordnung kontext andere möglichen
handlungen und da muss ich auf basis
dieser ganzen überlegungen reflexion in
dieser situation urteil fällen
moralisches urteil das kann ich nicht
generell mit maßstab sie erinnern sich
als total dimethoat es ist nicht mit dem
allgemeinen durchschnitt zu verwechseln
dass ich hier sein team
das ist nur das gut sein für die
gegenstände aber das gut sein für uns
zeigt er muss immer wieder neu aus
gemittelt werden durch reflexionen und
er würde dann wohl auch diese situation
muss man von fall zu fall schauen muss
man die umstände berücksichtigen muss
man abwägen muss man urteilskraft darin
erfahren muss man einbeziehen oder auf
dieser basis kann man dann pro tag
finden
als erster jedenfalls mehr an der
realität als kant es ist kann es
natürlich ein viel größer
ideal ist könnte man sagen da könnte man
natürlich kein zwar kann dagegen du hast
schon recht ganz klar denn es wäre
besser wenn jeder hier
die wahrheit zu haben würde aber in
diesem konkreten fall sind diese werte
bedroht diese interessen sind bedroht
hier geht es mir das leben des menschen
und da muss man auch ein bisschen mehr
konsequenz ils tischleuchte
militaristische das könnte man jetzt
kann entgegnen haben das kann dazu
prinzipientreue ist also wir schaffen
wir scheinen einfach bei moralischen
beurteilen immer auch die folgen
irgendwie einzubeziehen
die konkreten folgen und nicht die
logische
die menschen haben als solche gefahren
und dann könnte man sagen so was wir tun
müssen wir ins spiel kommen nach des
todes als wir müssen hier zivilcourage
könnte man als eine tote person
und da ist bei kant gar keine rede aber
er hat auch heute auf seiner seite also
absolut gesehen werden zeugen mehr
natürlich auch im falle eines mörders
nicht tun dann könnte man aber sagen wir
müssen das geringere gegen das größere
übel abwägen was ist es sicherlich nicht
richtig auch einen mörder anzulügen weil
wir den mörder auch die jetzt wirklich
alles menschen anerkennen müssen und
damit eben auch mittelbar der ganzen
menschheit schaden also wir setzen die
institution des vertrauens ausspielen da
könnte man sagen man muss liegt ein
geringeres man stärker nübel
unterschreiben und des geringeren über
diesen dieser situation bestimmt dass
ich jetzt eine unwahrheit sagen und das
größere übel das vermeidet damit nämlich
dass ein student gesehen wieder kann für
das sagen nein wenn ich ihn so recht
verstehen
größere übel ist jeder mensch hat in
gefahr zu bringen also die idee des
vernünftigen zusammenlebens zugeführt
das ist das größte und vielleicht nicht
sogar mal unbedingt der tod eines
menschen
hierdurch wird er hat vielleicht dann
recht wie man es sich so anschaut das
leben wirklich durch systematisches
lügen eben die das vertrauen der
menschen zu zerstören
das dann unglaublich schlimm es folgen
das ist sicherlich richtig aber man muss
dann bildung muss sagen hier wird dir
nicht das vertrauen der menschheit als
solche bedrohten hier wird das vertrauen
eines unmoralischen menschen dort eines
mörders und da muss man doch mal nen
unterschied machen also ich sehen wie
wir kann man verschiedene komponenten
mit anführen das ist ein sehr schönes
thema für eine mögliche chance arbeit
das können sie sich gut überlegen ob sie
das nicht mehr machen wollen wäre sehr
gut geeignet pro und contra dürfen wir
nur zum vergnügen dürfen wir nicht
verspricht verspricht für andere theorie
ja das eine gute frage wie denkt sich
bei diesen beiden anderen grundsatz da
ist da brauchst du was von konsequenz
service muss entfernt werden
wer lügt und dann dann glaube ich
dämlich und dann hat das diese folge er
denkt es auf eine gewisse weise schon
konsequenz allis tisch aber nicht im
sinne der handlung folgen sagt mir der
gefährdung an der struktur des
vertrauens als er denkt dass er im sinne
der logische es würde durch die lüge
nicht eine schlechte handlungen stehen
so ist würde unser zusammenleben als
kultur gefährdet und das ist keine
handlung wieder rausholen
das system würde gestört werden wie
seine stirn so erkennt es diese das
zusammenleben würde mit misstrauen mehr
durchsetzt werden und das ist nicht so
ist er jetzt eine konkrete handlungen
also wie wäre es denn jetzt sind es ist
auf eine höhere ebene und auf die
tieferen ebenen wiebels nehmen
es ist eine kunst strukturen die dadurch
bedroht dass die basis unseres
zusammenlebens wieder durch irritiert
und dann kann man sagen weil es die
basis unseres zusammenlebens ist ist
natürlich
der als der einzelne handlung die auf
basis so zusammen wenn es mal entsteht
so wurde
[Musik]
das ist richtig aber erkannt wird es
sagen ein wohnrecht erlaubt nicht ein
anderes wohnrecht also das jetzt ich
kann nicht einen rechnet man
irgendwelche bekämpfen ist also ich
mache das unrecht des mörders nichts an
recht mit dem ich an lügen indem ich ein
weiteres irgendwelche begehren unmoral
gar nicht bekämpft werden kann
obwohl wird sicherlich eine berechtigte
intuition haben ist etwas anzusehen
das weise zum beispiel sie kennen auch
diese diskussion koran im wort und
dürfen wir eine tür an tür
wir sind riesen diskussion
widerstandsrecht und so
sie sehen das problem ist nur wenn man
damit mal anfangen uns moralische
ausnahmen in anspruch zu nehmen dann
kann man sich fragen wo wir zwar auf wer
definiert wer hier der touran ist wird
definiert wer hier derjenige ist
gegenüber dem man ausnahmsweise mal ohne
plan shuttle darf sie sehen dass es der
missbrauchten türgriffe das war auch das
argument eines kommilitonen der letzten
sitzung wenn man mit der lüge einmal
anfängt dann
immer wieder dieselbe dieselben gründe
finden ähnliche hat oder sie sich so
schön reden könnte dass man wieder heben
sich natürlich gut aber landes mörder
sein ist natürlich etwas anderes könnte
das ist doch mal was ganz anderes wenn
jetzt direkt jemand bedroht ist
wenn sie einmal anfang zu vernunft und
es kann vernünftig als sich mögliche
ausnahmen zu beleben blieben und aus dem
gerät heraus nehmen des kategorischen
imperativ
er wird sehr schnell gefährlich
sicherlich außen punkte aber ich denke
die rechtsprechung die moderne würde uns
hier in jedem fall im gebieten dass wir
empfehlen nahelegen oder von uns
erfordern dass wir hier das opfer
schützen mit jedem erdenklichen mitteln
ich würde mir ein bisschen was ein
die juristinnen und juristen ein
verfassungsrichter eine
verfassungsrichterin dazu sagen würde
vielleicht finde ich dann anders als
wissen welcher schnitt liefers ging
danach mit diesen lügen dadurch etwas
dahin
bei einem rechtsphilosoph einer
rechtsphilosophischen platzes wagen gut
findest du wissen wie schütze ich glaube
dass tatsächlich die motivation auch für
die rechtswissenschaften nicht so
richtig ist es gibt zwar manche fälle
also zb heimtückischen zu lassen also
auf mord aus heimtücke
aber da habe ich gehört dass die
rechtswissenschaften der sehr skeptisch
gegenüber solchen motivation oder
benennungen von motivation wie heimtücke
dass man diesen arug am liebsten
streichen würde aus dem strafgesetzbuch
alter ist die rechtswissenschaft gar
nicht damit zufrieden weil es zu sehr
subjektiven sicht der wissenschaft
erscheint das objektiv verhandlungs- und
haben möchte und gar nicht nach den
gründen eigentlich fragen möchte das
interessiert hier einrichten wobei ihr
leben schon ein bisschen sauer auf
kanzlerin zeigt doch was wirkliche
moralischen schlechteste ist hängt uns
von willens ist dann würde die
rechtswissenschaft und interessiert aber
nicht was moralisch coole des
schlechtesten
interessiert nur was legal und was nicht
vegan ist für moralität des in uns und
wer werden so etwas wie heimtücke als
fall kennt der bewegt sich auf der ebene
der moral für uns ist es ein motiv
heimtücke
das ist eben nicht mehr um die
rechtliche deutlich kategorie trägt das
ist ein weiterer kategorie die in meinem
handbuch des unmoralischen land werden
muss heim zu geben
schauen sie sich schon wieder ein
weiterer punkt die liste ist prinzip
ihren abschluss
ok und jetzt kommen wir zu diesen netten
herrn hermann francke ist ein mit leben
zitierte professor in princeton
ich habe mir doch mal besucht und immer
gefragt ob er nicht nach münchen kommen
um mir ein meisterkurs war sehr
interessiert
aber er hat es dann doch irgendwie nicht
mehr hinbekommen schade aber ein sehr
interessanter denker und sie kennen ihn
vielleicht von seinen überlegungen zum
thema freiheit
dazu hat er sehr viel gemacht würden sie
weiter
das 70er jahren sehr sehr bekannt aber
auch und ganz bekannt für dieses
interessante buch hier im suhrkamp
verlag erschienen ist es eigentlich gar
nichts sondern es ist ihr ein kleiner sm
der sehr groß gedruckt und sehr
kleinformat ich eben als buch erschienen
ist und in diesem genau jetzt habe ich
gerade sich gerade partner aufeinander
komm mir also wenn man das ganze auf
youtube einer sagt aber wäre es mit
einer solchen praktischen zu objektiven
analyse nicht an die listen seien die
tourismus vor
also es ist sicherlich richtig dass
immanuel kant ein spezialist ist das
würde ich durch aussagen wie die listen
dem sinn dass wir ihnen eben nicht die
hand entscheidung ist sondern absicht
die motivation es würde mit eurem alltag
mit juristen und gitarristin bezeichnen
und person der es um die gründe motive
geht um das große ganze und nicht so
sehr um die konkrete situation und das
könnte man sicherlich kann diesen
idealismus vorwerfen sagen lieber
erkannt diese idealismus den du hier
moral verlust vertritt die ist nicht
adäquat für dieses beispiel des landes
das ist einfach eine andere welt und am
liebsten der falschen welt heißt das
falsche setting die falschen
begrifflichen rahmenbedingungen und die
tauben diese
nicht dafür eine sinnvolle antwort auf
dieses beispiel zu geben auch dieses mal
stille
das könnte man also durchaus kein
partner
wer hier ein weiterer kann italien
weitere nutzer sagt hier ein
einschlägiges zitat zum kronen position
august ist damit alles durch lügen das
ewige leben verliert darf man niemals
des zeitlichen lebens eine person mit
den flügeln also augoustinos sich das
ganze sicherlich ihr theologischer das
ewige leben das könnte man jetzt auch
ganz so beziehen
das
das mir wie leben durch die lüge
verloren wird aber eben die idee der
menschheit bedroht die menschheit als
idee des vernünftigen vertrauensvoll
zusammen
die würde dadurch bedroht werden ich
sagte in der letzten sitzung schon wenn
man das was bei den antiken oder auch
mittelalterlichen philosophen später
tieren mit also nicht christlichen
philosophen gott ist ist bekannt
prinzipiell immer das moralische gesetz
und wenn sie also setzt dir eine
praktische 15 das sieht ein bisschen
erlesene gebieten
und da gibt es ganz interessante stellen
bekannt und wir kommen auch noch drauf
nehmen wir diesen text über den eigenen
qualitäten
wo kann sagt dass das moralische gesetz
achtung gebietet und das ist dass wir
erhabenheit empfinden und so weiter und
so fort und dass die vom sinai also wie
vom berg sinai wo
der bibel kennt bestellt die cd wurde
entlassen sind
das sagt das gesetz hat eine solche
autorität gebot die uns an sie erinnern
wenn ich mich nicht irre
und da sieht man schon dass hier eine
gewisse ja ein gewisses säkulare form
von religiosität bekannt auch ins spiel
kommt und sind dieses absolutes dieser
absolutheit die hinter diesem sieben
gesetzte stehen jetzt können natürlich
kein vorgriff was hier so eine säkulare
eine säkulare form von theologie hast du
hier die politik transportiert und
theologie oder das absolutes solche
fragen an moralischen dilemmata keine
hunde springen kann man sich fragen aber
er kann wiederum sagen aber ich will
doch wissen was gut und was böse ist ein
guter geschlecht ich will es doch
absolut wissen ist doch keine sache von
mehr oder weniger jetzt absolut gut also
eindeutig als morgenstunden oder
eindeutig als alles schlecht zu
klassifizieren
das galt später wieder zurück also sie
sehen da gibt es immer verboten contra
argumente und sie können sich mit dieser
mit dieser thematik sehr gerne in einer
hausarbeit beschäftigt oder natürlich
auch in einer bachelorarbeit das ist
okay jetzt geht es also hier um dieses
thema wieder von harry
und hier seine spuren
es geht also die frage was ist jetzt
schlimmer lüge oder wie er es nicht nur
schüttet und sie wissen aber gar nicht
was bullshit ist
viele würden sagen lügen ist das
schlimmst würde wahrscheinlich auch
immer andere kann sagen
und jetzt hat aber hier wird nein es
gibt anderes phänomen das ist viel
alltäglicher würde er wahrscheinlich
sagen viel geläufiger noch viel
unspektakulärer als die hügel wobei die
möglichen als solches sehr
unspektakulären ist aber es ist genau
viel schlimmer ist es zu reiten das ist
eine interessante pointe der macht war
auf die idee käme man gar nicht weil man
im erst denken würde was auch immer
porsche ist lügen ist schlimmer lügen
ist gegen die wahrheit zu verstoßen und
schreibt für die these vertrieben
durchschritten ist deswegen schlimmer
als lügen weil sich verschiedene
überhaupt nicht um die wahrheit
während derjenige der die luft darin
immer auch die wahrheit an ecke das ist
so gebaut und es lesen sind noch mal
alles lügen ist eine hand mit einem
scharfen brennfunktion an einer
bestimmten stelle eine ganz bestimmte
ungehalten eine menge oder ein system
von bezeugung 1
um die folgen abzuwenden die eintreten
wenn an dieser stelle eine bereicherung
dazu bedarf es einer gewissen
geschicklichkeit der löhner sich
bestimmten objektiven zwängen verfügen
muss die sich aus dem was er für die
wahrheit hält ergeben wie lügner muss
sich ganz unvermeidlich mit den
wahrheitsliebe fassen werden möge
erfinden will muss glauben war ein zu
kennen und werden erfolgreiche mögen
finden will muss seine wahrheitswidrige
beratung im hinblick auf diese wahrheit
konstruieren als ich es sehen wir jetzt
mal 2 d
zum einen der wenigen deren die löwen
mussten gewisse intelligenz mit prinz
rekonstruieren und es geht um eine
gewisse geschicklichkeit war sein werk
der muss seine vernunft anstrengende
muskel wasser ohne das zweite ist die
lügnerin und lügner müssen die wahrheit
anerkennen sie müssen für sich glauben
zu wissen das zu weit ist und sie müssen
an dieser wm anknüpfen
sie müssen die lüge mit blick auf die
von ihnen glaubte wahrheit konstruieren
als die lüge setzt die wahrheit verlauf
ist jedenfalls für diejenigen deren
blüte das ist schon mal interessant
diese weil man würde doch normalerweise
sagen wer lügt interessiert die wahrheit
nicht also wer wird für den spielt die
wahrheit keine rolle
würde man ja normalerweise sagen also
prima fahrzeug könnte man das schon
sagen wir mögen den babys die wahl egal
und so ist es nichts mehr ging es die
wahrnehmung so wichtig weil er neben den
anderen personen an dieser wahrheit
abteilung recht und das setzt voraus
dass sie bereit für die blüten im ziel
wichtig
und jetzt auch noch mal ganz interessant
es geht also um eine mega ein system
überzeugungen positionen das ist jetzt
wieder ein bisschen analytischer stil
der event wird ist ein analytischer
philosoph und der geht ihm immer auf
wenn der sprachphilosophie
außenpositionen überzeugungen positionen
sind setzt jemand in die form ich glaube
ich denke ich willkommen
das alles was in diese das form passt
und das
das ist heute schönes wetter ist dass
ich im lotto gewinne
und so hat dessen position ich glaube
dass klar hinter sich gelassen und ein
solches system von positionen wird wann
die lüge hinein gebracht und sie bringt
dieses system durcheinander
ok weiter wer sich hingegen in
großschrift durchmogeln möchte bis
deutlich feier sein blickfeld gleicht
ihr einem panorama als einem brennpunkt
er beschränkt sich nicht darauf an eine
bestimmte stelle sein eine unwahrheit
einzuführen und steht daher nicht unter
dem zwang von unwahrheiten die diese
stille und geben oder sie kreuzen er ist
darauf vorbereitet bei bedarf auch den
kontext zu fälschen
diese freiheit von zwängen ergänzt
deswegen der wahrheit den der sich fügen
muss diesem fall bedeutet natürlich
nicht notwendig dass die aufgabe des
klosters leichter weder als dies liegt
aber die dazu erforderliche kreativität
ist weniger durchdacht und analytisch
als die beim lügen mobilisiert werden
sie ist breit und unabhängiger bietet
größeren raum für improvisationen farbe
und fantasie
hier geht es weniger um geschicklichkeit
als um kunst interessant also was m11
entfernt auszeichnet bis einsatz
er kann jedem noch so banal oder
unscheinbar oder auch suspekten phänomen
gegeben
dem burschen etwas analytisches ja
rationales abgewinnen
und das finde ich sehr spannend und es
scheint ihr außer das sind die aufgabe
der philosophie zu sein
dort wo man glaubt dass mit dunkelheit
oder begrifflichen leere herrscht da
noch strukturen aufzuweisen wie zb der
fall des unmoralischen viele würden
sagen acht unmoralisch oder acht des
bösen es existiert auch nur den katzen
oder wenn es gibt dann ist es so dunkel
dass wir es lieber meiden sein
da würde ich dann doch eher den
rationalistische stark und getreten zu
haben nein gerade da wo es und erscheint
müssen wir dem phänomen auf die spur
kommen weil es könnte sich viel an das
halten viele komplexe falls die gemeinde
denken wenn wir vielleicht uns auch
selbst enttäuscht werden
als er zeigt er hier der lauf ist
kreativ und der kurse
mich kreativ bzw
er ist schon kreativ aber diese
durchdacht kreativ und nicht geschickt
sondern er ist ihre künstlerischen voran
jetzt wissen sie aber immer nicht was
genau durchliest und haben sie schon in
die auf basis dieser partie die wir
jetzt haben was könnte hier schicksal
vielleicht wesen noch mal ein zitat
weiter
das wesen des bodens liegt also nicht
der tatsache dass er den angesprochenen
sachverhalte auch die überzeugung des
sprechers bezogen auf diesen sachverhalt
falsch daraus stellt das ist ein
typisches merkmal möglich
insofern sie etwas gutes der haut der
botschaft nicht notwendig
wahrheitswidrig sein muss und
entscheidet er sich von der rüge durch
die gefälschte tapst der bursche da muss
uns nicht täuschen und nicht einmal
täuschen wollen
weder hinsichtlich der tatsachen noch
hinsichtlich seiner vorstellung von den
tanz er versucht aber immer und über
sein vorhaben zu täuschen dass einzig
unverzichtbaren und unverwechselbar das
werk meines uhr schrittes ist dass er in
einer bestimmten weise falsch da
bestellt worauf er aus ist wird es im
klaren sind nicht gegeben wo es die
bullshit hier vorfinden oder sogar noch
ein bisschen weiter lesen ich sind der
unterschiedliche haben wie kann uns das
vorstellen steckte gegensatz zum lügner
vielleicht lebt man nochmal ein zweiter
das ist der entscheidung der hessischen
und im - sowohl der bursche da als auch
der blüten erwägen dem allerdings
falschen eindruck sie wollen etwas
wahres mittag und beiden verlinkte
erfolg davon ab dass sie uns in bezug
auf diesen umstand zu täuschung vermögen
durch der lügen dafür birgt vor uns
er versucht uns noch einer von einer
konkreten korrekten wahrnehmung der
wirklichkeit anzieht wir wollen nicht
wissen dass er uns etwas
wir sollen nicht wissen dass es etwas
glauben machen möchte was er selbst zu
fall steht der bodenstedter hingegen
verwirrt für uns dass der wahrheit' wert
seiner behauptung keine besondere rolle
wünscht
wir sollen nicht erkennen dass er weder
die wahrheit sagen noch die wahrheit
verbergen das heißt nicht dass seine
rede im prinzip wären sondern lediglich
dass die motive die sein tun leiten
bestimmt nichts damit zu tun haben wie
die dinge über die er spricht in
wahrheit sind jetzt wird es glaube ich
ein bisschen klappe haben sie jetzt ein
bisschen idee oder meinem beispiel wo
man aus solchen bursche antreten könnte
frankfurt bringt am ende dieses textes
den abgeschafft hatte diese zitate
beispiele wo man zu was häufig finden
jetzt hat sie doch schon weitere themen
hier bekommen überlegen sich im land wo
in der in situation haben sie geschlafen
gesteht produzieren oder vor der ihm
gegenüber uhr stellung beziehen und
erleben sind
an der universität
frankfurt hat mit ganz konkrete meinung
darf da 100 wo sich solche phänomene des
burschen zu treffen nehmen sie mal
gestern das vergessen europa
also fremd verdingt daraus ein bisschen
ein politiker wie kann man sich jetzt
genauer vorstellen
da bekommen es gibt da so viele genau
dass ich meinen jungs wäre sowas nenne
das war wo auch immer sie geäußert
würden könnte man sich jetzt überlegen
fake news sind nicht nur lügen sondern
fake news sind letztendlich spielereien
mit der wahrheit also raus sieht hier
irgendwas und es ist eigentlich ein
zugehalten sogar ziemlich egal ob das
was dann passiert war oder falsch ist
ein systemen wie durcheinander und ich
glaube das wird uns auf die richtige
spur der lügner bringen das system des
vertrauens durchaus in gefahr
sowas institutionen usw aber er bringt
nicht letztendlich das phänomen oder die
institutionen der wahrheit in eine tiefe
rezession institution der wahrheit auch
wenn natürlich niemanden mehr glauben
würde den mann da ist die wahl
ein bisschen betroffen aber die wahrheit
als solche das was man falsch ist würde
auch in einem system von lügen
eigentlich immer noch existieren können
wenn man würde eben niemand ihm nicht
trauen
aber man müsste schon immer noch dass
die unterscheidung zwischen war ein
falsches gibt und dass sie von bedeutung
ist auch wenn sie nun deswegen von
bedeutung sein sollte weil man eben so
braucht um leben zu können und der
bollstedter zu wenig für dastehen der
geht noch mal einen schritt weiter mal
der andere geht nicht mehr mit
unterscheidung zwischen wald und
zwischen lüge und wahrheit für den ist
diese unterscheidung völlig irrelevant
während sie von den lügen den immer noch
relevant ist das ist überall so postete
der ist wir im letzten zitat sagte vor
dem zitat der ist so eine art künstler
oder man könnte auch sagen was das
denken was nämlich dafür denkt sie
machen allerdings mal wie könnte man
diese menschen
deswegen ist das für die leute ist es
wichtig was wahr ist und was vor allem
und darauf die eine lüge aufbauen kann
lügner muss wissen was die wahrheit ist
weil nur dann kann er seine strategien
entwickeln und dann kann er seine
nationalität entwickeln was bis jetzt
wie können sie denn dieses künstlerische
jetzt auf freiem feld spricht wie
könnten sie das bezeichnen es gibt ja so
eine position der philosophie
das ist eine regel wird dieser titel
also zum beispiel könnte man es es gibt
die unterschied zum beispiel
relativismus relativistischen in diese
richtung könnte man das version
interpretieren das ist eigentlich total
egal ist man könnte es auch mit dem
unterschied von e mobilität und armor
all
die mobilität bedeutet einfach die moral
zu negieren
also letztendlich gegen die moral
verstoßen das wäre ein bisschen auch
neben den hügeln und amoralität mehrere
völliges desinteresse überhaupt an
normen die es geben könnte
also man könnte sagen das geht es ein
bisschen relativismus ist total egal
woher bringt ja auch ein beispiel er
sagt
er sagt dass das nicht unbedingt jetzt
nahe gestanden
bei der thermischen gewissen bis in
diese richtung geht es nach lesen wir
weiter jemanden chemnitzer verein ist
glaubt die wahrheit zu kennen zur
produktion von gold ist solch eine
überzeugung nicht erforderlich bernd
reagiert auf die wahrheit und sollten
zumindest in diesem umfang respekt ein
aufrichtiger mensch sei nur was er war
hin und wieder ist es unabdingbar dass
er seine aussage
der fall scheint also dass der löwen da
muss wissen dass er lügt für den club da
muss es wichtig sein den begriff der
lüge zu verstehen wer lügt er muss nicht
so sehr um die wahrheit natürlich weit
sich interessiert wird die beiden
passiert sondern für die lüge aber darin
steckt immer schon dass er auch die
wahrheit anerkennung ist hier legt der
muss einfach wissen das und er muss
wissen wozu erhöht und warum erlebt und
was er mit dieser lüge erreichen er muss
sich über seine eigenen zustände ganz
karben bis zum also zum glück ist
unabdingbar dass eine auf
für falsch der boden ist außen vor
besteht wie jeder auf der seite das
waren noch auf der des vorstandes als
die aufrichtige mensch oder als der
möbel achtet er auf die tatsachen nur
insoweit als für seinen wunsch mit
seinem behaupten durchzukommen von
bilanz zeigt es ist immer gleichgültig
ob seine behauptung die realität korrekt
beschreiben der beben sie einfach so aus
überlegen sie sich so zurück
das ist eine zielsetzung entsprechen als
der bursche könnte man sagen der
akzeptiert die unterscheidung von frauen
falsch ein nicht sondern der setzt
willkürlich wahrheiten flasche so wie
sie gerade als er spielt mit der
objektiv unterscheidung zwischen wahl
gefälscht
er kennt sie nicht an auch der löwen
spielt mit dieser unterscheidung aber
nicht so dass er das was war ist für
sich als falsch
das was falsch ist für sich als wahr
das muss der löwe immer tun der
burgstädter der ist noch da
ein bisschen radikaler für die meisten
menschen ist die falschheit eine aussage
kommt genug sind gar nicht erst zu
machen so schwachen vernachlässigt diese
grundaussage für den rechten von
augustinus als lückenhaft und ein
spitzenwerk lügner ist die falsche
aussage der gegenwart der gründe weshalb
das sie mag für den bohrer schüttet ist
die falschheit der aussage weder im
grund für das eine noch für das andere
menschen dass sie von ihren
überzeugungen sich der beschaffenheit
der leiden und zwar sowohl wenn sie die
wahrheit sagen als auch in syrien der
eine lässt sich davon leiten um die welt
korrekt beschreiben der andere um sie
falsch paar zustimmen aus diesem grund
fördert das löwen nicht in derselben
weise unfähigkeit zu behalten
dies wird das bullische wenn jemand
exzess in den vorstädten hin gibt also
nur noch danach fragen ob behaupten in
den kram passen
ich kann seine alle waren
identität darunter oder sogar von monti
lüftner muss immer noch
wahrheit oder falsche ecke ich bin mir
nicht mehr ganz sicher
man kann es natürlich in einem system
verstricken aus dem man nicht mehr
ausgeben
das ist sicherlich nicht es kann sein
dass man vielleicht am ende sogar
bullische landes wie eine spannende
frage
genau
schon 3 kommentare gerade das ist sehr
voll ist und färben im juni auf youtube
zahlen auch ein spannendes thema
angeboten alles können sie doch mal was
zu beschützen sagen was ist der
unterschied zum jubel
er sagt wenn es die unfähigkeit zu
wahren
die wahrheit selbst wird
die frage ist geht es bei können wir die
wahrheit selbst installieren der löwen
oder kontaminierte ziehen aber nur mit
blick auf die anderen mit bezug auf dem
ideen einbringen möchte dass der andere
wahrheit und falschheit vertauscht
aber für den lügen des selbst gilt
natürlich die unterscheidung von
wahrheit und falsch und der andere soll
in diesen verhältnissen getäuscht und
wie mir scheint gestimmt durchschnitt
und darin dass nicht nur den anderen im
verhältnis von walden falscher
durcheinander gebracht wird sondern auch
man selbst und das einem des aber begann
ist dass man gar nicht mehr interessiert
daran ist was objektive wahrheit ist
sind das nur
die konkrete situation dem maximalen
nutzen herausholen möchte und sich die
dinge so träge ist eben gerade passen
der lüner und der die wahrheit der der
wahrheit blickte mensch beteiligen sich
gleichsam selben spiel auch wenn auf
verschieden seien beide orientieren sich
an den tatsachen nur dass der eine sich
dabei von der autorität der wahl
bleibendes während der andere diesen
qualitäten zurückweist ist ablehnt ihren
anforderungen zu entsprechen
das ist natürlich in der anerkennung sie
kennen das die direkt der anerkennung
vielleicht schon mal gehört von läge
also wird die lüge oder wer die wahrheit
ablehnt der macht sich natürlich von der
wahrheit wieder unabhängigen aufgelesen
weil er muss sie ja als solchen das mal
erkennen um sie über ablehnen zu können
dann hat so ein bisschen was von politik
der bush ignoriert diese anforderungen
in tod und dance erweist autorität der
wahrheit nicht ab- und wieder setzt sich
nicht wie es den juden tut der ist
letztendlich indifferent gegenüber der
wahl der lügner muss sie bekämpfen
man erlebt da muss ein interesse so ist
ein interesse für die beiden nämlich die
wahrheit zu verdanken aber daran müssen
wir die wahrheit anerkennen müssen sie
muss eine bedeutung für uns haben auch
wenn nur eine negative bedeutung
ich will nicht dass die wahrheit
rauskommt aber dadurch hat die wahrheit
für mich wert auch wenn imker treffen
werden und
seine botschaft ist es so dass die
wahrheit überhaupt wird er beachtet sie
einfach nicht aus diesem grunde nicht
nur schön größter feind der wahrheit als
die lüge und es ist ja schon eine starke
these viele würden von ihnen hier nicht
sagen das was auch immer geschieht ist
dass es immer das nicht so schlimm ist
wie lügen und hermann reith und
kommentar und der lügner und nur hinter
den gewinn bzw
in wahrheit nach dem motto ich mir etwas
falsches sagen und das nur weil des
falsches das hörspiel ist ich mir nicht
ich glaube nicht dass der lügner nur um
der lüge willenlosen der lügner lügt um
eines bestimmten zweckes will für den
eben die wahrheit letztendlich
verdunkeln und ich glaube nicht dass es
menschen gibt die nur 1 oder dem es nur
um das lügen geht das ist sicherlich
richtig aber es gibt sicherlich fast von
der situation denen einem geben
die unwahrheit wichtiger ist als die
wahl eines bestimmten interessen als er
hat es immer mit bestimmten interessen
zu tun und diese interessen sind ansicht
eigenen erst mal ich sage ist positiv
aber es ist ein zeichen von rationalität
also man muss etwas ernst nehmen es muss
für einen rest von bedeutung sein um
überhaupt auch nötig zufolge oder logo
zu können die welt und was für mich von
bedeutung sein auch wenn ich vielleicht
in einer lüge milch selbst meine
interessen über die presse zu setzen
aber für mich ist etwas an bedeutung
mir ist nicht gleich gut und was
frankfurt hier kritisieren scheint ist
das eigentlich die welt gleich geliebt
ist ja dass damit viel größere
gleichgültigkeit verteilen ist wer sich
darum bemüht den tatsachen gerecht zu
werden oder sie zu verschleiern erkennt
damit an dass es tatsachen gibt dem
gleichmann irgendeiner weise erfassten
erkannt werden können wenn er die
wahrheit sagen oder wenn er lügen möchte
setzt er voraus dass ein unterschied
zwischen einer richtigen einer falschen
sicht der dinge und das ist zumindest in
manchen fällen ist diesen unterschied zu
binden
wer dagegen nicht mehr an die
möglichkeit glaubt das stimmt aussagt
als war anderem gegen zeus zu weisen
die bleiben nur zwei wege entweder steht
in jegliche versuchen ein gewaltiges 2
das bedeutet auch tatsachenbehauptung
ganzen ganz verzichten tatsachen
behauptet profession umsätze mit dass
glaube dass die oder er stellt weiterhin
behauptet auch mit den anspruch auf eine
beschreibung der wirklichkeit erleben
aber nichts anderes als nur schön sein
können als hätte man erweckt den
anschein dass ein paar positionen tätig
war heizwert fähige aussagen die auch
das interesse an der wahrheit suggeriert
aber man macht das nur der form und
eigentlich geht es am überhaupt nicht
auf diese proposition bau geforscht
auf dem köthener geht es darum dass die
proposition bade vielleicht ist sie soll
im falsch sein was er sagt aber das
setzt im internet wieder an ein
interesse an der wahrheit voraus in der
und dieses indirekt interesse dass
lasten der wahl
und das fängt beim futter wie frankfurt
main track porsche ist immer dann
unvermeidbar wenn bestimmte menschen
dazu zwingen
und jetzt kommt über die mehr zu regeln
von denen sie nichts verstehen
das betrifft jeden von uns die
produktion von porsche wird also dann
angelegt wenn ein mensch und der die
lage gerät oder gar verpflichtet ist
über ein thema zu sprechen das heim
wissenstand hinsichtlich gebe das thema
relevanten tatsachen übersteigen diese
diskrepanz findet sich häufig im
öffentlichen leben in dem menschen sich
aus eigenen antrieb oder auf
anforderungen anderer oft getrennt sehen
sich eingehend über geben studien aus zu
lassen von denen sie war in dieselbe
richtung wirkt die weitverbreitete
gezogen
in einer demokratie seine bürger
verpflichtet meinungen zu allen er denkt
in dem es entwickeln oder zumindest zu
all jene fragen die für den öffentlichen
angelegenheiten von bedeutung sind
das fehlen jedes die pikanten
märz zwischen den meinung eines menschen
und seiner kenntnis der realität wird
natürlich noch gravierender bei einem
menschen das ist eine pflicht als moral
stimmen das wesen hält ereignisse im
zuständigen halten der neuerdings
geburtstag
ich kann mir eine kleine geschichte
erzählen ich hatte mal harry frank wird
auf einem vortrag in chicago getroffen
und der beim anblick und dann fiel im
vortrag eines redners ein begriff ein
fremdwort und hat sich gemeldet und
gefragt was bedeutet dass er betrifft
verstehen
also ich versteh ich verstehe nicht mehr
und darin entschieden dass ein bisschen
diese tugend enthalten sein für die er
hier bleibt also ein wunsch hätte wäre
zb jemand der unnötig viele fremdwörter
benutzt oder jemand die eben unbedingt
mainz allem viel gesagt etwas sagen zu
können oder nicht sich mal getraut zu
sagen ich habe leider keine meinem
herzen
ich hab' ich kann dazu nichts sagen das
übersteigt einfach mal
und ich glaube jeder kennt es das man
gerne zu einem immer besser
oder so ein bisschen aus was sie an sich
eigentlich nicht problematisch ist ich
finde aber man muss eben dann aufpassen
dass man an dem punkt wo man wirklich
nicht mehr kommt von dir etwas sagen
kann also sprich grünen führen kann dass
man da dann einfach sagen ich weiß es
oder hier verlass ich meine kompetenz
ist und er scheint jetzt damit mit
durchschnitten das zu meinen dass wir
eben uns danken ein jahr ein
überschreiten unsere kompetenz und
wollen einfach nur über sagen damit es
gesagt ist sie kennt es auch das wissen
wenn da einfach nur was sagen also floss
können sich einfach auf sich bemerkbar
macht mit floskeln wollen dann
letztendlich jeder zeit zur wahl zu
bewegen wenn man einfach ausgehen können
an einen schweizer feldspieler kontrast
zu gerade heute auch csu-mann
allgemeinen sprachgebrauch die beete
unterhaltungs mindestens zehn ideal das
ist ein guter punkt lüge ist ja nicht
nur die falschaussagen das ist ja nicht
die flötistin verfügen sagt die falsch
ein
stimmt ab und nehme ich die ware
schneider und ein bestimmtes ziel damit
seien möglich ist nicht nur falsch
machen zb kann als eine person sagt p &
poor's s&p es macht daraus gold nicht
dass die person libyen
es könne nämlich sein dass es person gar
nicht war jetzt das pack 1 also die
person muss um zu leben
psa am penis falsch und sie muss wissen
dass er falsch ist und ich will noch ein
weiteres und weiter und von mir zu
nehmen nämlich sie mussten wissentlich
dass es falsch ist um ein
bestimmungszweck zu erreichen und aus
der tatsache dass sie meine hand ist
dieses die forscher nicht als daraus
eine zwischen- und das ist der konzern
wagens pcs gewöhnlich das de facto sie
muss es wissen
und sie muss wissen dass jemand anderes
es nicht weiß und sie muss mit diesem
wissensvorsprung den sie hat diese
enttäuschung vorstellung der eine
täuschungsabsicht vor verfolgung und
daraus einen gewissen gewinnschlag
dann erst kam das mit einer lüge zu tun
fragen werden nicht dass es ist
dabei
weil ich eben nicht konkret weiß dass es
falsch ist aber auch weil ich nichts
hier war dass ich etwas mit
genau dem was ich wohin sagte das öl
über sagt als weil man einfach
überfordert ist von als kleines beispiel
man kennt jeder für sich bestimmt man
weiß ja jetzt zb in talkshows oder so
ein tag
das sind typische wirklich jetzt mal
behaupten konstellation von bor schicken
ich spreche nicht gegen die institution
einer talkshow aber wenn sie sich mal
hinein denken sie sehen und publikum das
heißt es hier ihre eingeteilt ist ein
bisschen auch übrigens jetzt hier in
diesem moment kamera internet
ich muss aufpassen dass ich kein
bullshit beziehen aber in der talkshow
ist es so da ist man dann als experte
eingeladen
hier gibt es ein publikum die kameras
sind auf eingerichtet und dann gibt es
die moderatorin moderatorin und man
fühlt sich geschmeichelt wenn dann
irgendwie in der frage ein kommt oder
man will jemand anderen unterbrechen
oder korrigiert und ganz schnell ganz da
geschehen dass man einfach über was
redet ohne wirkliche chance wissen wo
rede war hat die kamera auf eingerichtet
ist in der politik ist es auch läuft
gefahr dass man einfach seine komplette
überschreitet und vielleicht dann nur
noch etwas sagt damit gesagt wird um
aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen oder
vielleicht mit dem was man sagt anderen
menschen schaden möchte oder nicht aber
die wahrheit kann
[Musik]
dann muss man einfach also zumindest
glaube es muss einen tipp genau genau es
muss ein interesse seien an der wahrheit
und das bedeutet auch dass wir müssen
wissen muss wenn man nicht mehr die
unterscheidung zu spalten falsch halten
treffen sie kennen den punkt ab dem
stück punkt könnte sagt ich kann nicht
mehr tun und das war falsch ist ich habe
p
sie kriegen zum einsatz und sie sind so
lange möglich oder machen es sagen
solange sind
optimale gleich müssen damit sie wieder
sein können wissen dass sie tun so als
ob er werde mit der bestimmung interesse
aber sie wissen dass gefallen und wenn
sie nicht mehr wissen ob wahr oder
verdeckt ist aber der gob b sagen und
mit pia kommentieren
dann sind sie wird genau so müssen denn
sie müssen wissen dass sie das nicht
entscheider fest und dann soll und sie
nach frankfurt und ich finde zb nicht
mehr verwenden oder sich auf peso
beziehen besorgen ich weiß nicht ob der
fall ist für mich also redet darüber
jetzt nicht mehr vielleicht weiß jemand
wissen und ich glaube eher nein zu
wachsen also ich würde es sehr wichtig
da eben auch darauf hingewiesen gerade
nochmal youtube chad das leben bei der
löwe eine täuschungsabsicht enthalten
sein muss das ganz richtig wenn man dem
botschafter muss gar keine mehr die
frage ist bei den gauchos folgenden
täuschungsabsicht vorlieben bei den
burschen was die texte folgen
dass man nicht unterschreiben
als der coach möchte die anderen traurig
dann endlich da enttäuschend dass wir
nicht die bahn sondern da enttäuscht
dass er nicht weiß was sonst keinen fall
stammtischen genug mit den anderen
enttäuschen dass er eben nicht immer
angst also dass interesse besteht in
anderen nicht wissen zu lassen dass der
freistaat der andere soll getäuscht
werden darin dass nicht die so tut als
ob man die man sagen würde
auch wenn man dabei ist das die wahrheit
ist immer die falschen ist und der
bursche bedeutet hin und leute glauben
mag dass er vielleicht entweder lügt
oder die wahrheit sagt am besten durch
die beheizung obwohl er nicht weiß dass
ob das was er sagt sondern als faktische
noch eine tiefergehende enttäuschen weil
hier nämlich noch nicht mehr wahrheit
vorausgesetzt
kann die beim lügner vorausgesetzt wird
ein sehr ruhiger war es ausgehen würde
es enttäuschend dass es eben nicht ist
er macht mir die nation
also wenn der bürger weiß sp möchte den
anderen glauben machen das neue oder
wenn er glaubt dass nun möchte den
antrag glauben machen dass bieten und
der geburtsstätte möchte den anderen
darin täuschen dass eines waren okay
aber dennoch gegen die nun besser
sollte es allerdings die bearbeitung
daneben hat in seinem buch ist ein buch
ja
eigentlich falsch ist und dass das
besonders gegen sagte
nach dem angeln kann schon weil da geht
es ja um die maxime dass irgendwann
erzeugung und das ist eben dass man
überzeugung zufälligerweise verdoppelt
falsch sein könnte mehrere vereine etwas
besser aber sie holt punkt wie verhält
es sich zu der wahrheit die er nicht in
mir wächst die ausnahme familien und
deswegen ist man muss es wird also noch
mal konkretisieren
es geht gar nichts irgendwann oder
falsch umgegangen
ob ich glaube dass es falsch ist also
meine gründe dafür ob es richtig also
muss man vielleicht noch ergänzen der
lüge wer muss grünen gedanken haben zu
glauben dass prp und er muss diese
gründe so einsetzen dass in anderen
damit deutsche es kann natürlich sein
dass er immer die falschheit für die
wahrheit aber an seiner motivation in
anthrazit finde das natürlich nicht da
ist kann wieder sehr subjektives tisch
gibt es noch andere beispiele als mir
scheint haben sie noch andere phänomene
burschen
haben sie sich schon mal gewaschen als
ich bestimmten dann bestimmt auch schon
mal seminare nutzen wenn ich irgendwie
nicht richtig wussten aber dann müsste
man jetzt einfach mit eine tugend
entwickeln und die tuben müsste eben
seine skepsis bescheidenheit ehrlichkeit
und was kann dem jetzt zu boden schicken
führen jetzt mal übergang zu immanuel
kant oder thomas mann gewesen aber in
der letzten viertelstunde wie ich hier
todsünde kann dem symbol schütte führen
muss nicht meinen tod sind jetzt seien
aber welche form des moralischen führt
dazu dass wir bevorzugt
nehmen sie doch mal her top chance
suchen
[Musik]
genau eingehalten so was kann die
gegenwehr der verbreitung von
botschaften ursachen auch in diversen
formen eine skepsis muss der uns die
möglichkeit eines zuverlässigen zugang
objektiven realität absprechen behauptet
wir können es sich gar nicht erkennen
wie die wirklich sind sagte von
relativismus wie sie an die realistische
doktrin untergraben und zu übertragen in
den wert und voreingenommene bemühungen
um die verklärung der frage was war und
was falsch ist und sogar unser vertrauen
das konzept einer objektiven forscher
eine reaktion auf diesen
vertrauensverlust bestehende abliefern
jeder vorne disziplin durch unsere
folgen eines ideals gerechtigkeit
erforderlich ist und der hinwendung
seiner disziplin dieser die verfolgung
eines alternativen ideal so fordert das
jetzt zu tun nämlich eines sozial ist
ihr auch wichtige station erster linie
um die richtung eine richtige
darstellung der gemeinsamen willst
wendet sich der einzelne dem versucht so
eine aufrichtige darstellung seiner
selbst zu geben und der überzeugende
qualität besitze keine innerste natur
die als wahre natur der dinge zu
erkennen der hoffen dürfe bemüht er sich
um wahrhaftigkeit in den blick auf seine
eigene werke es ist als meinte er
da das bemühen um tatsachen teuer ist
ganz sinnlos erwiesen haben müssen
versuchen sich selbst polizist
interessant man kann sie jetzt wagen
macht ihr jetzt frankfurt eine
psychologische analyse
das hat er schon so ein bisschen was von
der psychologie entwickelt aber
letztendlich glaube ich dass es auch
eine form von man von philosophie es dir
hier entwickelt gegen alte nochmal eine
weitere form von des unmoralischen
nämlich so was wie also relativismus in
die ventizz muss und noch nicht rügt die
dazu passt und es vermeiden das würde
die aufrecht wir wurden in diesem jahr
und wir schauen wie wir diese ganzen
form eines unmoralischen durch durch
formen der tugend wieder beheben
wir schreiben
oder nutzer wann sind die diese gründe
aussagekräftig genug um von burschen war
war zu gelangen reicht etwa plausibler
glauben oder ist überzogen notwendigen
ich glaube schon dass man sie glaube
reicht musste neben gründen muss gründen
angeben
ich muss mich gründen operieren und in
dem ich mit gründen operieren will ich
wieder die wahrheit finden also wer mit
gründen operierte der gründe gibt
der ist an der beiden gründe geben und
nehmen auch zu nehmen also gib mir eine
rechtfertigung dafür bedeutet dass ich
wieder an der wahrheit sind dh der
großstädte scheibe auch nicht so richtig
zu argumentieren das ist auch der lueger
hingegen der argumentiert ganz schön
viel der boostedter argumentiert nicht
richtig was wird der brüste machen der
würde wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen
auch ein bisschen tricks auch anwenden
und das wirklich zu einer
philosophischen richtung in der antike
die vielleicht mit dem was frankfurt
porsche mit besonders heran sein könnte
haben sie die wm gekämpft immer beratung
oder der sog dessen zahlen die morgen ja
genau die sophisten also das scheint
hier so ein bisschen dahin depression
der bursche ist ein modernes ist dem
geht es nur darum erfolg zu haben und
die waldschäden nicht die sophisten die
haben wahrheit nur als ein handelsgut
betrachtet und die rhetorik die in die
nur dazu den anderen zu reden aber nicht
überzeugen bezeugen dazu muss ich die
wahrheit immer im hintergrund haben und
die welt geredet für den ist die
wahrheit und nur mittel zum zweck
das rechts glaube ich ziemlich gut der
der sophisten und sie kennt es auch im
akademischen da möchte meine zeit noch
ein buch schreiben ordentlich und ob das
wahr ist was darin schreibt das
interessiert mich es muss ein
wunderschön aussehen sagt ja auch so
kreativität es muss irgendwie tollen
titel mit dem fremdwort haben das muss
bei mir furchteinflößend sein es muss es
sein und dann wird aber vom 14
dann bin ich gerade an akademisch
abrutscht ich glaube auch gerade nicht
an der politik nicht nur torchancen
gerade auch hier wohl ich stehen wird
wurde getötet
und da ist jeder gibt mich davor gefeit
da hier steht an diesen platz aber
natürlich auch in ihren reihen sitzt
also auch an der uni prozess ist
bullshit leider sehr hoch
aber jetzt soll es mit dieser
selbstkritik genug sein
lesen noch 1 punkt weiter es ist jedoch
eine groteske vorstellung
ich will damit nicht sagen dass sie
jemals produziert das war alles bisher
sehr wieder sehr weise falsch weil sie
diskutieren ich glaube auch dass familie
aber wieder mit nur darauf hinweisen
dass in akademischen kreisen eben auch
nötig ist nicht nur der palette
es sei doch eine protest gefolgt und mir
selbst sein fest und wissen und klar
bestimmte wesen die sich richtig oder
falsch beschreiben könnten werden dass
ich als unsinnige wesen haben einen
anderen irgendwelchen anderen team klare
bestimmungen zu weisen
als bewusst gewesen existieren wir nur
in der reaktion auf andere dinge und
können uns daher womöglich selbst
bekennt ohne du bist jetzt
zu erkennen außerdem stützt nichts in
der theorie und erst recht nichts in der
v die absurde thesen menschen am ehesten
noch die wahrheit über sich selbst zu
erkennen
die tatsache hat außer dem konzert sind
keineswegs besonders solide und
resistent gegen eine auflösung durch
skeptisches denn in wirklichkeit sind
wir menschen schwer zu packen gewesen
und zur natur ist notorischen in
stabiler und weniger ein gewisser als
metro unter den und angesichts dieser
tatsache ist aufrichtigkeit selbst das
ist eine interessante these also was
will er damit sagen haben ist jetzt
aufrichtigkeit selbst bullshit
[Musik]
diese bestätigen durchstoßen ich hab's
gern
[Musik]
ausschließlich sein weil ich eben doch
schon bin
genau
[Musik]
ja ich glaube dass das zugedacht ist
auch vielleicht haben sie noch andere
haben sich nicht glauben dass so was wie
aufrichtigkeit auch häufig denn so eine
form der selbstgerechtigkeit umschlagen
kann dass man sich anschauen der
aufrichtigkeit nehmen sich gibt und sich
selbst bewegt selbst
was bringt mir damit sagen möchte ist
eigentlich dass wenn ich ihn recht
versteht dass man sich selbst immer
wieder kritische fragen zu dass man sich
nächstes sicher darin sein sollte
aufrechte sagte sich wenn ich richtig
stehen auf der anderen seite wiederum
argumentierte geben so ein skeptizismus
reagiert sagte möchte er werden und es
muss nicht vertreten aber wohl des
kindes muss nicht bezug auf den 10
und darin scheint mir für ein verzehr
katalanischen fans immer anerkannt
vertreten wie thomas von aquin bestimme
mal also der hatte eben hier
ein bisschen mit dem hoch motor gefaltet
wird er jetzt noch mal zur zweiten
freunde in den letzten fünf minuten über
weil wir auch ein bisschen später
begonnen hatten nämlich wie kanten
eigenen dünkel bestimmt und wie sich
dieser zu boden verhält das möchte ich
ein bisschen waren
ich springe ein bisschen vor dem gehen
darauf auch in der nächsten sitzung
wieder ein bisschen ausführlicher 1
hier ist er im anerkannt und in seiner
kritik der praktisch geübt sagte
folgendes allem neigungen zusammen die
auch wurden einträgliche systeme
profitieren können und deren
befriedigung als dann einige der
seligkeit heißt machen die selbst zog
solis muss raus diese ist entweder die
der selbstliebe eines über alles geben
wohlwollens geben sich selbst die
frontier oder des wohlgefallens an sich
selbst heranziehen
jene als besonderes eigenleben
diese beiden denken also eigene dunkel
ist markant ganz entscheidet also das
wohlgefallen
an sich selbst dass es der eigentliche
und zwar hin die mit dem gehalt und same
den neigungen mit dem was uns angenehm
erscheinen und die wir nach langen
wollen unglücks ist ganz interessant
weil darauf richtet sich kant gegen die
eucharistische wäre der antike die
gesagt hat qualität und glückseligkeit
und möglichkeit gehen hand in hand und
kann sagt nein
dieses bestreben glückselig zu werden
glücklich zu werden
geht er hand in hand mit humor nehme ich
mit so was dass wir uns selbst
nun gehört der haben zur selbst schätze
mit zu den meldungen gehen das
moralische gesetz ab oktober werden jene
bloß auf der sinnlichkeit als er sagt
dass auf dieser kategorische imperativ
das sieht ein gesetz das das leben
gerade gebietet dass wir nicht nur so
behandeln sollten dass es uns gut sind
dass bei ihnen mit interessen der
anderen menschen berücksichtigen das ist
also eine konflikt ich bin mir noch
nicht so genau
nun finden die aktion natur als
sinnlicher lesen so beschaffen dass die
materie des regierungshandelns geben
schnell der neigung ist sei der offen
oder furcht sich zuerst auftritt um
unseren pathologisch bestimmt dabei
selbst ob es gleich durch seine maxime
zur allgemeinen gesetzgebung ganz unten
ist dennoch hat gleich als ob es unser
ganzes selbst ausmacht ist seine
ansprüche vorher und als die ersten und
ursprünglichen geltend zu machen
bestrebt ist typische kantiger satzung
und kann diesen hang sich selbst nach
dem subjektiven bestimmung skaten seiner
willkür winkels des entscheidung suchen
zum objektiven bestimmung dass wir uns
überhaupt zu machen
die selbstliebe
welche wenn sie sich gesetzt geben und
zwar unbedingt den praktischen prinzip
macht eigenen dunklen heißen kann
es soll das letzte szene setzen gewisse
zeit ganze dazu noch ideen was es jetzt
genau der alpen dürfte gegenüber der
eigenen liebe und die selbst in wärme
die selbstliebe und was ist der
unterschied zwischen selbst sie mit ein
es geht um eine handlung
worin bestehen
bisher mit dem eigenen zusammen ja
[Musik]
genau richtig das hat als es selbst sich
nicht nur die maxime selbst sagen sie
völlig recht sondern dass man meine
maxime oder mein wille der auf die
befriedigung von einer ziemlichen
naturerziehung alles was mit neigung zu
tun hat so allgemeinen prinzip macht das
ist er einnimmt als im reigen dunkel
geräusch ich nicht mit dem sittengesetz
dem kategorischen inhalte der forderung
zukunft sind eigenmittel bereich der
forderungen meiner ziemlich natur also
letztendlich mein kann damit meine
individualität im eigentlich habe ich
meine individualinteressen
eigeninteressen zum absoluten die es in
bestimmten schichten und das ist der 1
als nicht verkehre das ganzes im gesetz
nicht mehr die vernunft es meint maßstab
um allgemeine vernunft die rationalität
zu dem markt wird meine individualität
in meine wohnung
bedürfnis die werden zu lassen mal statt
die werden so weit wie wir in einem land
das erkannt ist eine opel ja das sollte
für heute auch gewesen sein es gibt ein
paar zitat die wir da zu lesen können
und wir kommen in der nächsten sitzung
noch einmal kurz zum eigentümer zurück
und waren dann ganz gewohnt wie wir es
uns belegt hatten
im seminar plan weiter ich bedanke mich
für die rege diskussion im plenum
vertraut hier dem schritt verkauft und
münchen nach einem guten start
[Musik]